[Musique]
bonsoir les enfants bonsoir
patron ne faisons pas de bruit ce soir
je crois que nous allons avoir une
nouvelle
pépite ah oui pepita on est un peu
sauvage il ne faut pas l'effrayer mais
je crois qu'elle va venir nous voir dans
la roulotte
mon échelle et au pop hip hop hop hop
hop
lui fit cachalots bonsoir tout le monde
doit on croit bien que je te peu [ __ ]
elle n'est pas venu non pas encore mais
dès qu elle approchera taisez vous étiez
vous d'accord lorsque je la perds ce
vrai jeu tout serait pour vous avertir
jouable ou à quelque chose où je
m'entraîne
nous avions compris shirt atta
nous n'avions pas besoin de répétition
mais cette fois c'est vrai
[Musique]
las
manos nan nan nan nan salut [ __ ] t'es
tout ça mais oui mais [ __ ] dit tu veux
des bonnes loisel j'en ai trouvé dans la
forêt moi j'ai prouvé un joli hérisson
tu bois tu l'aies
est-il avec quoi non il est chez moi là
là là là là là là non tu n'es pas malin
tâche est fou
yes une petite fille qui vient chercher
des noises et c'est vrai on ne souffre
pas j'ai quelque chose à dire il est 3
heures c'est mes amis qui vont tout
donner prenez les nicolas oui tu les
connais je suis vu par la fnac où ils
sont très gentils et nounours aussi fils
et
tu veux jouer avec nous tous ensemble
peut-être vous trouvé une pépite arts
vient vous voir
oui mais tu sais il est aussi gentil
qu'il est gros merci bonjour petite
pépite d'or tient une jolie rapid at il
sèchement à cache-cache pepita
tiéné capitao tu as beau bijou capitale
est-ce que tu traînes dans les âpres
doucement vous allez lui faire peur avec
toutes vos questions tiens pepita un sac
de noisettes tout freud
merci monsieur moore ce toujours avec
nous n'a mal oui dans la forêt
[Musique]
c'est elle est mignonne
monseur nounours et ses enfants sont
fatigués excusez-moi shirt à ta bonne
nuit les petits
couchez-vous vite je me sens bénie nous
nous que la nuit vous apporte calme et
repos
[Musique]
alors nounours elle est venue patron et
nous avons fait connaissance
je lui ai fait très bonne impression
elle m'a fait des compliments 1 est
adorable damier allons-nous nours aux
routes bonne et les enfants fait de bois
[Musique]
oh